welcome to this video this is alvaro
Alonzo Alva Alonzo probably the new
opponent never played him before it
seems from Spain yeah lots of spanish
players don't they have great weather
then why do they play chess all the time
ok we have them the Trump going for this
a very solid line 92 e of course that's
a very simple way to play it as wide
it's not very likely to let any big edge
but it's ok let's see you just eat six I
guess oh that's interesting where is he
going to g3 yeah c5 I might get into
some some issues with Bishop b5 hmm ok
let's just play it conservatively
likessee 593 Bishop g6 Bishop piayed we
should be five and ok probably wants to
go G form
no but that I don't really think that
this is very dangerous
G for Bishop g6g for I simply have h5
okay he can play that I mean g4 Bishop
g3 Bishop g3 g4 Bishop g6 Bishop d3 for
example trying to play yeah okay but I
thought h5 should be very much okay now
of course it's not like that this is
unplayable or anything but it doesn't
doesn't bother me very much Queen B 6
smelly tickling Emma don't be too yeah
should I go see 5 or or not yeah I'm not
sure yeah but probably it's a good idea
i need some sort of porn break I need
some form break and it makes them
probably wonder if you should play
Knight g3 or Bishop g4 i will take and
politics okay yeah I wanted to take care
anyway so night be 64 is something that
looks very tempting
and that i didn't expect but maybe it's
not that bad okay this intending Roxy to
looks looks like a good start I can go
Roxy one and I'm sure that this was a
good good idea not nothing now give this
this I don't know we'll see one I didn't
really have a good good reply yeah in
any case let's see that not falling too
much behind on the clock Ian hmm yeah so
night here and night see form is the
idea I can maybe play 9 p-5 now and the
tech a 7 the night before I and that was
stupid i played this too quickly i
should have played a 6 first night b5
queen bee aight queen a 5 or queen bee
form might be a might be tricky
hmm no that's not good or maybe maybe I
can hear okay seems to be useless to
calculate anything is playing something
else in any case might be five looked
dangerous to me maybe I'm seeing this
wrong but doctor looked it looked looked
like problem
this is just just very okay for black
because he has he has weakened himself
so much so I should try to double on the
sea foam he also has a three hanging
this is why b3 is always a bit bit
difficult on controversial let's say
move that might haunt white later okay
not not clear forbid what you should do
now I have an easy plan rook c8 Quincy
seven probably are also I can what would
be ideal getting the Knight to f5 nights
e87 f5 also very problematic um I wonder
if I should do that actually but I can I
should do this first it's difficult for
him to to even move anything okay so i
don't have a night route takes takes
there any other way to get the night via
a 8 this is the long way hmm this next
month is 92 right takes rook checks and
then I'm just winning a pawn so long as
I'm there winning a porn queen c7 is not
doing that much now let's let's see what
he's doing next time night see one I
really just take it and take a three not
really seeing how i'm going to activate
this night easily but it's very
difficult for him to play a movie i was
just giving up the pawn you're always
doing that which is really not not
really attractive um how do we do this
now probably here Quincy 7 and the
Knights e8e seven ok he had an idea ok
my night is coming to his seven
now this was of course a good defense I
die all looked at 9325 not very
difficult in fact but I still didn't
appreciate the idea I know that's nice
g3 g4 as well so Jack to do that not
only for us definitely definitely a
handy handy piece okay now how we how do
we do that I'll take it probably not I
want I want to invade of course maybe
take and Queen B 6 and 10 like 15 yeah I
thought that I can get in on the light
squares but he's still defending that a
five eyes got Quincy 70 Quincy seven as
a counter play maybe I need to go for
counter maid is okay checkmate okay yet
eight seconds so this was very
problematic to defend yeah I I really
didn't didn't think about this count to
play with the night coming to e5 around
here black of course has a very nice
position Oh interestingly enough the
computer sinks its equal yeah maybe I
was also a bit a bit puzzled because I
really don't see how I quickly get the
night at five but then okay the
computers is now slowly am getting the
evaluation up yeah rook 82 c 7 is better
now i was thinking about that intending
intending this but what I really forgot
is that after here I was only thinking
about the capture
what I thought is that I couldn't take
now on a 3 fc7 hangs this is why I
didn't go here but after this i can just
do this move and this is just good
that's important like here and now i get
in get in this yeah this is this is a at
least better for black not not quite
sure how much better but like a spaten
yeah so the way it went so I really
didn't think about it that's stupid when
okay spits it's nothing nothing terrible
i mean here the computer is giving black
a very clear interesting yeah maybe it's
really not mattering that much that the
night comes to you hive yeah now we are
we are talking about the wind chat did I
miss something here the check here Queen
B 6 stronger maybe I'm 94 look area look
very tempting but you can't expect
traffic player with a little time yeah
now we run it ran into the make that he
had eight seconds so it's it's it's not
nothing to be ashamed of a certain name
in the sky I love our Alonso roselle no
don't know them and don't know him is a
ton of has got a ton of games on the
eyes to see but we never played ok I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching